come on in the water is warm joe
in april of 2019 then presidential
candidate california senator kamala
harris
was gently ribbing former vice president
joe biden
who hadn't yet announced whether he
joined the already crowded democratic
field
just a couple days later and biden was
all in
that's why today i'm announcing my
candidacy and the race was on
contentious moments between the two
often leading the news cycle
early front-runner joe biden taking hits
on stage from senator kamala harris
kamala harris just knocked this guy on
his
seat it was clear to me when i watched
that that kamala or kamala
is not running for vice president she's
running for president
just over a year later they've gone from
primary sparring partners
to political allies i don't hold grudges
and i've made it really clear
that i don't hold grudges mr biden
fulfilling his campaign promise to
choose a woman
has named ms harris as his running mate
which would make her the first black
woman nominated for vice president
by a major party her selection comes at
a time of national reckoning on matters
of race and
justice here's how her career and life
story
brought her to this moment my parents
first met
as graduate students at uc berkeley
where they were active in the civil
rights movement
my father donald came from jamaica to
study economics
my mother shamala came from india to
study the science of fighting disease
ms harris grew up in oakland california
graduated from howard university in
washington d.c
then returned to california for law
school she became a prosecutor and was
elected district attorney of san
francisco in 2004
and then in 2011 attorney general of
california
in 2017 she became the first black
person to represent california in the
u.s senate
i say we must measure up to our words
and fight for our ideals because the
critical
hour is upon us in january of 2019 she
announced she was running for president
let's do this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
on the trail trailing senators elizabeth
warren and bernie sanders in the polls
that spring
she voiced positions appealing to the
party's progressive wing
they say you oppose legalizing weed
that's not true i know
and look i joke about it half joking i
have my family's from jamaica are you
kidding me
but it was mr biden who was the
frontrunner and in a debate at the end
of june last year
she took him on holman gann on his
record on race
the freshman senator confronted the
former vice president for comments he
made
about working with segregationists in
the senate decades ago
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me i did not
praise
racist that is not true do you agree
today
that you were wrong to oppose bussing in
america
then do you agree i did not oppose
bussing in america what i opposed
is busing ordered by the department of
education
mr biden returning fire raised questions
about ms harris's career as
a prosecutor i was a public defender i
didn't become a prosecutor
it was after that debate last summer
that ms harris hit her high water mark
in the polls
kamala harris surging to second place
speaking to the national urban league
ms harris defended her role as a black
woman who worked in law enforcement
why do we only have to be on the outside
on bended knee are trying to break down
the door shouldn't we also have a role
on the inside
where the decisions are being made in
one debate mr biden accused ms harris of
failing to disclose to defendants not
available
as attorney general of california where
i ran the second largest department of
justice in the united states second only
to the united states department of
justice
i am proud of the work we did work that
has received national recognition
for what has been the important work of
reforming a criminal justice system
and cleaning up the consequences of the
bills that you passed when you were in
the united states senate for decades
as summer turned to fall ms harris fell
from the top tier
her campaign was faltering she was also
failing to catch fire with black voters
and her party's progressives
then in december she dropped out of the
race my campaign for president
simply does not have the financial
resources to continue
she is really a solid solid person
and uh we're loaded with talent but i'm
sure she's not dropping out and wanting
to make the changes she cares about
after mr biden's big victory on super
tuesday
political earthquake these are the
results nobody saw coming
i just wanted you guys to know ms harris
told her supporters i
am with great enthusiasm going to
endorse
joe biden for president of the united
states i believe in joe
back in the senate in the aftermath of
george floyd's killing while in police
custody
she became a leading democratic voice
for reforming law enforcement
where is the accountability and
consequence when they abuse that power
our bill is designed to address just
that
we are seeing people putting their
bodies on the line in the face of more
excessive force and tear gas
to stand for equality for all people now
the 55 year old senator joins mr biden
for
an unpredictable three months this
movement will not
accept anything less than real real
substantial substantive solutions
it's a new chapter in her career coming
at a time when
the movement for racial justice and now
she herself
are at the forefront of american
politics